ever occurs so i want to be your partner
in this
i want to be able to join with you and
the rest of the members really
of the senate but particularly those
hard hit areas because it is uh
it has been very very difficult
to try to rebound from so with that
i would say um unless you want to make a
comment
uh i would say we're about to wrap up
madame chamber before we wrap up
one last thing for a long time the
delaware did not use when i was governor
we didn't use the economic development
administration we didn't use eda
and as it turns out we didn't have a we
hadn't produced the kind of
comprehensive economic development plan
that eda was looking for in order to
make us eligible to apply for grants
one of the grants we we obtained from
eda
about a year or two ago was to
enable uh to take money raised by
believe it or not uh auto dealers
by our poultry processors and
eat an eda grant uh and
the idea was to work with our statewide
community college delaware tactical
community college
to create uh something that uh
uh where we uh the center for automotive
excellence
and we now have in southern delaware or
county seat of georgetown
a delaware technical community college
top of the line
to attract and retain folks to work for
auto dealers
and vehicles of the future do other the
maintenance work
to work for the poultry industry all
their trucks and so forth
and uh but we did it with the help of
the eda and we work with our community
college
and the i think there's something there
in terms of retraining and retooling
we have jurisdiction over eda right
that's the good news we have
jurisdiction
the in the um the biden proposal build
build back better they ask for three
billion dollars three billion dollars
for the eda
we've never done more than about 300
million in a year three billion it's a
huge amount of money
and i think there's a chance to partner
in a more creative way
to help meet the the skill sets the
needs that
in the marketplace but also that a lot
of folks give given the opportunity to
lose learn their skills
they do it and they're doing it we're
signed up fully at the
center for automotive excellence in
georgetown well i look forward to the
eda
uh discussion i i i think that we've
used the eda actually
really well in west virginia most
recently uh on a lot of different
infrastructure development and job
training and
and development and so i do think it has
a place because it is for
underserved and unserved areas so i look
forward to working with you
on that so i just want to really thank
you've been an excellent witness
uh i think uh that you've answered
questions with a lot of honesty
and uh and your promise to get back to
people is very much
appreciated um i think there are no more
questions so members may submit
follow-up written questions for the
record they're called
qfrs here and by 4 pm on friday february
the 5th
the nominee i would ask secretary regan
to respond to these questions by 10 am
on monday um february the 8th so there
goes your weekend
and um i would like to thank secretary
regan
uh for your time and testimony and thank
your beautiful family for
being here with us and um i wish you the
best of luck well thank you so much it's
amazing
okay
[Music]
oh